if President Ronald Vikram singer wants
to reach out to the tamils in Northern
Sri Lanka arresting those demonstrating
against his visit is probably not going
to help University students and
political activists in jaffna Spoke out
against the president's visit on
Saturday
but they face the same treatment as
anti-government protesters in the south
efforts to reach out to the Tamil
Community has its roots in the Civil War
of the 1980s and 90s when Tamil Tigers
took up arms against the government the
community said it suffered unfair and
unjust treatment by the singhalese
majority
the Tigers were crushed in 2009 which
led to accusations of gross human rights
violations by the military
vikrama singha who is dealing with a
major economic crisis is under pressure
from the International Community to
address those wrongs
earlier in the day the president
attended a ceremony to dedicate a Tamil
Cultural Center gifted by India
let's get together and go on this
journey to rebuild this Fallen country
then it will be everybody's country
ahead of his visit the president ordered
the return of 42 hectares of private
land taken over during the war some of
it still occupied by the police military
and government institutions
rajasekharam Thunderman's land was part
of that return his property was occupied
by the Army which he says filled his
Paddy fields and built on it we asked
him how the occupation affected families
like his very very badly you know they
have only small lands you know they
don't have any other houses or anything
they went out other workers this way
from here they go in straight in point
Pedro Thunderman's family has other
properties still under military control
President Ronald Vikram singer opened
the cultural center behind me and is
promising to address the long-standing
Grievances of the tamils including
implementing the 13th Amendment to the
Constitution which would give them
greater autonomy this Drew immediate
protests from the Buddhist clergy who
have opposed the amendment from its
passage those watching the developments
in the north are skeptical that autonomy
is Within Reach how is he going to
handle the protesters how is he going to
tell them what they are doing is wrong
at a time he is being challenged for
other reasons right so it's going to be
very difficult for him to to do that 36
years after being introduced the
Constitutional amendment is still an
issue for many here
Tamil say their leaders must be willing
to go beyond it to truly address their
grievances Mila Fernandez Al Jazeera
jaffna Northern Sri Lanka